Nous sommes au cœur du golfe du Morbihan sur la petite île de Gavrinis
des chercheurs viennent de réaliser la première
numérisation en trois dimensions des gravures du site mégalithique
découvert en 1835. "Très vite la réputation du monument s'est fondée sur
justement la profusion de ses gravures et la beauté des agencements géométriques que vous allez découvrir."
"Notre venue ici est
concomitante à la fin d'un programme de recherches qui a eu lieu sur la "table des marchands", le fameux dolmen à Locmariaquer
et comme les deux monuments sont
liés par le fait même que leurs deux dalles de couverture
sont les deux fragments d'une même stèles, qui était érigée à Locmariaquer,
il nous a semblé intéressant de prolonger le programme de la "table des marchands" vers Gavrinis
avec pour objectif principal
d'enregistrer à nouveau ses gravures
qui font la réputation du monument pour les interpréter. Est-ce que ces gravures sont pensées véritablement pour l'architecture, ou est-ce que ces gravures
renvoient à des stèles et qui étaient signifiantes dans un autre contexte?
Ou bien certaines des gravures, voire même la majorité, ont été pensées pour l'architecture de Gavrinis et à ce moment-là,
il faut essayer de comprendre ce programme
dans l' architecture telle qu'elle nous apparaît aujourd'hui avec un couloir et une chambre."
"L'origine du programme, c'est enregistrer avec les outils d'aujourd'hui, c'est à dire
le laser, c'est à dire la photographie numérique,
pour établir des modèles tridimensionnels, de telle sorte que l'on puisse
avoir un corpus de base qui soit le plus fiable possible puisque jusqu'à maintenant on était obligé de travailler sur
des documents qui avaient déjà 30 à 40 ans,  qui étaient bons pour l'époque mais qui sont maintenant insuffisants."
"C'est nécessaire aujourd'hui pour aborder n'importe quelle architecture.
Gavrinis est une architecture du néolithique, donc en tant que telle, il nous faut des plans et des élévations précises comme n'importe quel bâtiment.
Donc ça c'est le b à ba de de la lecture architecturale.
Après il faut essayer surtout de de replacer les gravures que l'on enregistre,
par exemple par photographie avec un éclairage tournant, sur un modèle numérique de terrain, j'allais dire. En tout cas sur une surface qui est... qui
n'est pas plane. Or tous les relevés jusqu'à maintenant que l'on retrouve dans les livres c'est des gravures qui sont en deux dimensions.
Donc là on voulait absolument mettre en exergue le relief de la pierre
de telle sorte que l'interprétation de la gravure tiennent compte de cette morphologie du support.
Donc ça, c'est... il n'y a que l'enregistrement tridimensionnel pour... pour l'obtenir